congress is set to vote today on the
covid relief deal so
what's in the 900 billion dollar bill
congressional correspondent chad program
he's live on capitol hill with this hi
chad have you been able to read all 6
000 pages
no they just posted the bill text a
couple of moments ago and we should have
a meeting of the house rules committee
around 2 45 pm eastern time the rules
committee is important because that's
the gateway to put bills on the floor so
a vote
is in fact coming at some point today
and this would be the fifth coveted
package
but some lawmakers are asking why it
took so long
republicans believe house speaker nancy
pelosi could have taken a deal
months ago she did not want to give
president trump a win and meanwhile the
american people were losing things main
thing we rejected was
a bailout to a lot of blue states who
have mismanaged their funds but
meanwhile we were asking her
to at least let businesses have another
bite of the apple at monies that were
already appropriated
the bill provides 600 dollar stimulus
checks for many americans a sizable
chunk of the legislation goes toward
the paycheck protection program it's
designed to keep businesses afloat
the bill also extends an eviction
moratorium and there's money
to distribute the vaccine
who do you think these vaccines come
into estate
they go from the lab to your arm
magically no they have to be received
distributed administered
the white house indicates president
trump supports the bill now we're still
expecting a vote
they just posted the bill text as i said
a few minutes ago the hold up
was a computer glitch dana
all right chad thank you so much let's
bring in senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell who
of course was part of these negotiations
and senator
i want you to have a listen to speaker
nancy pelosi whenever a deal like this
comes together
each side tries to say that the other
side caved here's how she spins it
what took so long what took so long
is because we could not get our
republican colleagues
to crush the virus i couldn't understand
it
why would they not want to invest in the
science
that has told us so importantly that it
required
testing tracing treatment separation
sanitation
and the rest
senator how do you think um you would
describe the delay in getting this deal
to fruition today well dana the facts
are not irrelevant
uh i said back in july what the country
needed was a package
roughly a trillion dollars focused on
kids in school small businesses
health care providers and direct cash
payments
we tried to pass we
started advocating that in july and
august the talks were unproductive
so i essentially put that bill on the
floor of the senate in both september
and october
not a single democrat supported it their
view was
give us everything we want or we won't
give you anything
well so it's noteworthy that at the end
they finally
gave us what we could have agreed to
back in july
i think what held it up was they did not
want to do
anything before the presidential
election i think they felt that that
would disadvantage the president
but look we finally got it done we got
it done
in exactly the same amounts as with the
same
uh configuration that we would have been
able to do back in the summer
but for all the intervening election
shenanigans
on the side of the speaker and
democratic leader
schumer what about for people out there
so many of them are hurting
facing eviction their bills are piling
up their restaurants are closed
they really want to work but they can't
that feel that this bill even is
too little too late and that congress is
out of touch with what people are really
going through
it's not too little too late it's
directly targeted at exactly what the
country needs
right now if after the new
administration comes in
they want to advocate more we'll take a
look at it based upon conditions in the
country at that time but look the only
thing that will stop
this dilemma is the vaccine and it's
going out
being distributed all over the country
we're going to get the country
vaccinated as rapidly as we possibly can
that is the only way we ultimately get a
handle
on this problem let me ask you about the
vaccines because i know that you got
yours last week and
there's a little bit of grumbling from
some people saying that members of
congress should not
uh be getting this before other
americans are but
you have a unique experience with
vaccines including
the polio vaccine and in fact you had a
statement that we'll put up here and
i'll let you talk about it but you said
that you know both the fear of a disease
and the extraordinary promise of hope
that vaccines bring
tell me a little bit about your thinking
about how you want peop people
to know what you want people to know
about the vaccine and why you think they
should take it
well look first in terms of the order of
taking it we were designated by
a public health outside group to take it
because of continuity of
government concerns second i think it's
important for the leaders in the country
to step up take the vaccine and help
reassure the american
public because polls indicate about half
the public is either skeptical about
taking the vaccine or doesn't want to
take it at all
that has to change because we can't
solve this problem
until large numbers of americans are
vaccinated
as a polio victim myself i fully
understand
the significance of vaccines it took
decades to develop the polio vaccine
this vaccine was developed
in under a year a modern medical
miracle and we need to take the vaccine
let me ask you about the fact that
you have this deal that came together
and you have the republicans in the
majority but you have these georgia
senate runoffs
taking place on january 5th and that
will those races will determine
which party is going to maintain control
if you recall i'm sure you do
when president obama had the majorities
they were able to pass obamacare they
almost passed cap and trade
they got that big stimulus deal with
shovel ready projects that weren't ready
does anything that happened in those
last few weeks
of coming to this deal on covid relief
point you in the direction of what you
want people to know about how important
those georgia senate races are to you
well the georgia senate races happen to
land right in the middle of
this coronavirus agreement
leaving them aside for a minute what the
country needs is exactly what we're
going to pass
later tonight the georgia senate races
however do determine
whether or not the democrats will
control the entire government
and what we fear is if they control the
entire government
these movements to defund the police and
move us in the direction of socialism
will have new legs i don't think that's
what the voters voted for on november
3rd
i think the the fact that house
republicans did better
than anyone anticipated the fact that
senate
republicans did better than all the
pundits said indicated the american
people were voting for moderation not
far left
winning in georgia guarantees that the
new president will be a moderate
because he won't have any choice
his new incoming deputy chief of staff
jen o'malley dylan
she had some choice words for
republicans that she gave to
glamour magazine last week using an
expletive to describe republican
lawmakers but singling knew out in
particular saying that
mitch mcconnell is terrible
what do you think when you hear
something like that when you think that
this they say they want to work together
they want to get things done
well that that kind of rhetoric is is
not helpful i i know the new president i
know him well
that's not the kind of thing i don't
think he would have said and my guess is
she was probably taken to the woodshed
after saying that
[Music]
do you anticipate that in the new year
you would have another chance to do a
coveted relief bill will there be
another one
and at that point do you think you'll be
able to get liability relief for small
businesses into that package
yeah i think liability relief is really
important it's not just for small
businesses dana it's universities
it's non-profits it's hospitals
doctors nurses this epidemic of lawsuits
is already developing
these people need to be protected
because they were doing the best they
can with an unknown
disease and if there is another
coronavirus relief bill after the first
of the year
i'm going to insist that liability
protection for these universities and
health care providers
is a part of it all right
well we wish you a merry christmas thank
you for coming on the show today senator
thank you diner